this weekend the kids from the George
Soros funded never again movement took
their childish message of living to
adulthood to DC the turnout for the
March for our lives rally was sure to be
as small as the activists themselves not
a lot of people here the energy is
surprisingly low they say the camera
adds 20 to 30 people I would definitely
agree with that you guys can be quiet I
mean half the people here are here for
the cherry blossoms other days it's
putting on a hell of a show right here
with more than a million people
participating in the March for our lives
across the country welcome to the
revolution this information was
everything from MSNBC to ABC to The
Daily Show
all right cafe gotta get that popcorn
fruit I'm going to earn each delicious
morsel of shrimp by exposing some of
these kids who don't know the first
thing about guns in America we spent 35
hours in the classroom and if anything
students on the front line of this
battle here's the problem you guys don't
have perspective you're in it these
things affect you directly you need okay
okay you're out of your lanes I came out
today because
affected my family member died from gun
violence I think it's important to Stop
gun violence on the streets generations
I wanted to speak to that is there any
way you guys could step down who paid
you to say that we care about guns why
do you care so much about gun I don't
want to get shot I also have a good
point which is don't come at my guns bro
I get you notice to me so I wasn't
surprised to see kids obsessing over
this hot new protesting fad but as I
looked out on this sea of teen optimism
I noticed something even sadder and even
desperate her adult trying to get all up
in on this whole activism thing all
these adults trying to fit in with kids
is wack it's so not thrilled Fuji okay
maybe I'm supposed to act like a youth
but this is not
social activism is think it looks as
good on adults of skinny jeans like
everybody trying to regain like the
glory of voting for Al Gore we do want
to inspire I mean like oh yeah it looks
in front of the inspire yeah there's
nothing more lame that lives co-opting
youth culture trying to act all it cool
it you weren't a beanie you where I got
my I got my underwear so people don't
actually cared about gun violence why
didn't they do something about gun
violence before took the kids standing
up to say hey please don't leave me I
know I haven't done anything that's been
my whole plan these adults and kids were
doing something devious they were
uniting and amplify in their message
which means love and Betty we went to
the woman's March together and the
immigrants March made Americans march
like a socialism bingo right there
that's not what family to produce but to
sit silently in a room and be angry at
each other if your midlife crisis is
making you spend more time with your
family then you're you're doing it wrong
Wow parrots just don't understand about
right is this the new American family
you inspiring parents inspiring families
to work together towards change it's not
how I was raised
thank you mom and Greg so thankfully for
us this rally and therefore the entire
movement was coming to a close
good it's over we don't need to talk
about guns anymore hashtag never again